Das ist wirklich unglaublich bisher wurde es nur vermutet jetzt wurde es durch versuche bestätigt
spinnen können sich mittels elektrischer felder
fortbewegen und wie sie das machen dass es wirklich
sensationell also jetzt wie es funktioniert und wie weit die spinnen damit kommen den krieg ziehen science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir haben ja lässt sich darüber
berichtet wie einfach effektiv und schnell evolution funktioniert in afrika gibt es immer mehr elefanten ohne
stoßzähne dafür sorgen die wilderer die die elefanten mit stoß sind töten die zeugen so weniger nachkommen und die ohne
stoßzähne dafür umso mehr und schon sorgt diese
auslese für das langsame aussterben der elefanten mit stoßzähnen es ist schon eigentlich ziemlich simpel es überleben immer die lebewesen
mit leicht besseren eigenschaften und bilden dann
irgendwann die mehrheit und zum schluss sterben die anderen aus es bleiben im fall der elefanten diejenigen ohne
stoßzähne übrig außer die umweltbedingungen ändern sich irgendwann in diesem fall wäre es das beenden der wilderei
ja und für die spinnen bedeutet das dass arten die sich verbreiten können einen deutlichen vorteil gegenüber
arten haben die sich nicht verbreiten können oder deutlich langsamer ausbreiten können was hat sich die natur
dafür ausgedacht bzw was ist entstanden welche
eigenschaft hat die auslese entwickelt flügel haben ich bin ja nicht und so haben sie eine wirkliche high end technologie entwickelt die sie
ohne wind fliegen lässt und das ist wirklich extrem spannend beobachtet wurde das seltsame flugverhalten der
baldachin spinnen schon vor langer zeit schon charles darwin
beobachtete wie hunderte kleine spinnen an einem windstillen tag auf seinem
expeditionsschiff be gelandeten und mit hoher geschwindigkeit wieder davon flogen und schon im neunzehnten jahrhundert
wurde spekuliert dass die spinnen mithilfe
elektrostatischer kräfte flogen doch erforscht hat und dass bisher niemand und so war es reine
spekulation jetzt hat eine forschungsgruppe der university of bristol das geheimnis gelüftet und es ist wirklich spektakulär
basis war das elektrische feld dass zwischen der oberen atmosphäre
und dem erdboden besteht bei gewittern können wir sogar einladung zwischen den beiden polen des feldes beobachten wenn es blitzt
die stärke des feldes ist also sehr
unterschiedlich und nicht immer können spinnen es deshalb nutzen doch dem team gelang es ein so schwaches fällt oder
richtig schwaches feld aufzubauen das genau die bedingungen
widerspiegelte die die spinnen zum fliegen benötigen sie konnten das hält zudem an
abschalten dann setzen sie die spinnen in diesem raum auf eine startplattform und achteten darauf dass es keinerlei
luftbewegung gab und tatsächlich schalteten sie das feld an hoben die spinnen
abschalteten sie es aus sanken sie langsam zu boden die baldachinspinne
nutzen dazu eine wirklich
ausgeklügelte technik sie recken ihr hinterteil in die luft dann
stoßen sie mehrere fäden aus fächern sie auf und das elektrische feld lässt sie abheben ihr kennt das
vielleicht aus eigener erfahrung wenn kleidung aus kunststoff aufgeladen ist dann werden die körperhaare
angezogen auch sie haben quasi ab die natur hat daraus eine
flugtechnik konstruiert jetzt will das forschungsteam das phänomen weiter untersuchen können die spinnen zum beispiel dem flug durch
verlängern abwerfen der fäden und so weiter beeinflussen wie weit fliegen sie ja vermutet werden hunderte kilometer weit
es gibt also noch viel zu klären wenn er keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollen dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgeht er die kaputte aber boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen als ich schicke euch vorher eine nachricht vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach
darauf blicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür
da klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
gefährliche mückenart in deutschland bis dann
bleibt dran